I want to start by saying how much I
loved this movie one of my favorites of
the year so excellent and now I'm done
okay I'm good I love the cinematography
the weightier goes and Robbie shot this
movie is amazing can you sort of talk
about working with the two of them and
the brilliant cinematography yeah I
actually asked mule Gus the other night
if he's storyboarded and he said no he
doesn't that he he and cinematographer
and talk through kind of shots that they
like shots that they didn't but actually
each day we would arrive on the Sat play
out the scene and he would then kind of
compose the camera then and there they
we barely ever used laid any track he
really wanted to hear a technical talk
about it technically I can't tell but so
the camera was on wheels so he could
just design the shots around the acting
say he was very free flow your Gus um I
loved the dancing just so spectacular
what what was it like filming that thing
it was we had to rehearse Joe I went to
myself had to rehearse for about four or
five weeks we were taught by a
Argentinean avant-garde dance
choreographer called Costanza and it was
hard it was challenging and then when we
actually had to do the dance we were in
costumes to Joe's and heels I was in
heels and a corset and a headdress and a
six foot train so some of the moves had
to be changed to adjust to the court to
the costume this is one of those films
that people are talking about an award
season like in the Oscar race and stuff
what does it mean for you to be part of
a movie that's in being talked about for
like Oscars and stuff you know to Mogis
which is very recently the film had its
world premiere at the Venice Film
Festival which was a very prestigious
event and Olivia Colman won Best Actress
there I don't know if you know that I
don't know yeah she won the Volpe Cup so
we're really we're really hugely
celebrating that because it's an
incredible thing that happened this film
has it's unusual it has three great
female leads three great female
performances talk a little about the
script if you will when you got it if
you knew I need to do this thing
certainly when I first read the script I
I felt that I would
yeah I would I would do anything for the
role not as much as Eve Harrington and
in All About Eve but I would definitely
knock on your gases door and say please
please please um thank you so much and
again one of the best of the year thank
you so much
you